دخلنا الى محرك البحث جوجل وسالناه عن خبر
اعتقاله دونالد ترامب بعد مثوله امام
المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي واذا به
يرتدي بزه برتقاليه وربما يمكث في السجن
منذ سنوات
[موسيقى]
صور اخرى انتجها الذكاء الاصطناعي فيها من
التزييف العميق ما وضع ترامب في عراك مع
الشرطه خلال اعتقاله بعد هروبه في الشارع
والحقيقه ان ترامب غادر المحكمه وتوجه الى
نادي الجولف الخاص به في نيوجيرسي للقاء
مناصره
ان تهديد بالسجن لمده 400 عام لحيازه
اوراق الرئاسيه وهو ما فعله كل رئيس اخر
تقريبا هو احد اكثر النظريات القانونيه
بشعه على الاطلاق التي تم طرحها في محكمه
قانونيه امريكيه قانون التجسس يستخدم
لملاحقه الخونه والجواسيس ولا علاقه له
برئيس سابق يحتفظ قانونا بوثائقه الخاصه
خبر اعتقال ترامب مصدره شبكه التي قال
مراسلها بعد مشاهده ترامب يدخل المحكمه ان
ترامب
رهن لاعتقال الان لينتشر الخبر في العالم
كالنار في الهشيم
كاد خبر اعتقال ترامب ان يتسبب باحداث عنف
خارج المحكمه وربما في ولايات امريكيه
اخرى مصير من دعى الاعتقاله من معرضيه لم
يكن هينا هذا الرجل استفز مناصريه رمب
خارج المحكمه ارتدى ملابس السجن ورفع
لافته تدعو لاعتقاله لينال بعض اللكمات
قبل ان يتم توقيفه من الشرطه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات